just wondering um what
do you know she's on birth control by
chance
uh yeah no she's not brandon's mom
is on a mission to get his russian
fiance
julia on birth control which is honestly
something she has
no business doing because uh she's not i
mean i'll be happy to take her over to
the you know to the doctor when she gets
here
plus my heart goes out to mike who looks
like he's about to be stressed out
this entire season just four days before
natalie was set to come to america
she asked him to kick his uncle beau out
of the house
if he's around here for a couple days
then you're just gonna have to suffer a
little bit
you're joking no i'll tell you her
reason why
in just a few hey
90 day fans fam it's melisia
the original series that started it all
is back for season eight
and based off of the premiere episode i
think it's gonna be an interesting ride
i definitely have some opinions so let's
go ahead and get into the biggest
takeaways starting things off with 90
day newbie
brandon in his extremely close
relationship with his parents my dad is
one of my best friends
you're acting like a pig
this is my baby boy brandon
i'm betty i'm his mom
my mom can be a little controlling
always trying to tell me what to do
they look just alike she's definitely
giving me
debbie vibes but sweeter
[Laughter]
controller yeah so brandon
lives on a farm with his parents and
because he is in debt
he's gonna be staying there with his
fiance julia
who's coming from russia on a k-1 visa
now there are a few problems just
bubbling up under the surface here all
right
one brandon's parents don't really trust
her
which is expected two
they're making brandon and julia stay in
different rooms which
she has no clue about and three
brandon's mom is all up in julia's
uterus
trying to get this 26 year old woman
on birth control cause uh
she's not i mean i'll be happy to take
her over to the you know to the doctor
when she gets here
she's willing to take a chance you know
i guess i mean you guys can do other
things to make sure that doesn't happen
i don't know if i really want to take on
that kind of responsibility
either what are you saying
that um i guess we're not being safe
you're not what
oh that's not good that's not good
no that's crazy that is crazy i think oh
absolutely
he said is it yeah it is
i guess now we see why his parents hover
over him so much
brandon needs a bit of help making adult
decisions
alright the birth control situation
it was taken to the next level
when brandon and his parents were in the
car headed to the airport to pick up
julia
and his mom's phone rang hello
well thank you doctor for calling me
back um
yes my son's fiance is coming into
town one of the things that we're
concerned about
is she has not been on any form of birth
control
betty are you her mother
are you you all my mouth dropped at this
point
because as a grown woman
if i was to know that someone was having
this discussion about my body with a
doctor
without my permission
i would be offended i would be
and i would be terrified knowing that
i'm about to have to live with you my
mom's on the phone with a gynecologist
right now
i did not expect this at all she can
call whoever she wants to she can talk
to him
is that going to change anything no she
can't make julia's decision for her
i just think that they need to be on
some kind of birth control
you know it is something that we'd
rather see her go on sooner than later
okay awesome thank you so much for
calling me i really appreciate it
they're going to uh help out and give
julia a consultation as to
you know her options her options for
birth control that's
excellent you know that makes me feel
much better they are just discussing
birth control
like it's this simple medication
and it's not it's not
it affects women differently and
sometimes
the effects are drastic i'm just
interested in seeing how julia
is going to react to all of this
especially after brandon revealed
earlier in the episode
that she's against the medication and
doesn't want any part of it
alright let's move on to mike and
natalie
when i learned that these two were going
to be on the season i was shocked
their issues are so massive
and they don't seem happy
they just don't plus natalie
she barely accepts mike for who he is
he's not religious but she wants him to
be
he's a big guy who likes steak but she
wants him to be vegan
i mean the list of their problems
it goes on but they're here so
let's talk about them during this
episode natalie revealed that she got
her visa
and mike is preparing for her to arrive
in the states
in four days how you doing love come on
booboo
are you excited for me to come i'm
excited i'm nervous
i'm scared i'm everything in between
why is good because there's just so much
baby you know what i mean
i'm scared to you know if you're gonna
be comfortable i'm scared if you're
gonna be excited i'm scared if you're
gonna like the place
just thanks buzzer smee
and what's that what is uncle wall
just a refresher beau is mike's uncle
who lives with him
and helps him work the land on his farm
but
at this moment according to mike he's in
seattle
visiting his son uh he is gonna be on
his way back he's been over there for
the last couple days
oh no he's on his way back here
but uh you know that i will not stay in
the house as a stranger i mean
i need my time videos like a travel time
okay at first i was thinking natalie
girl
you're tripping it's not that big of a
deal but
then i put myself in her shoes she's
traveling
across the world to stay with the man
who she's admitted
to not trusting now i didn't say it was
smart but
that's what she's doing this man lives
with his
uncle and there are no women in the
house
on top of that there are also some
reports out there that uncle beau
doesn't have a squeaky clean past so
i get her concern this also seems like
something they've discussed
already it's not like he's a total
stranger to you love you guys been
talking you know
i'm not just gonna like kick him out and
say all right well good luck
we gotta find him a place we gotta help
him
if he's around here for a couple days
then you're just gonna have to suffer a
little bit
you're joking no
i don't i don't know we i gotta work on
it just like i said
you won't be alone all right
i'm hoping me and natalie can discover
ourselves in this 90 days
and we can truly fall in love and
uh it all works out but only time will
tell
well the teaser for the rest of the
season
tells us that it's not going to work out
and mike is sending her back to the
ukraine
which i'm honestly not upset about
that relationship it just feels so
heavy i feel scared because it's kind of
the virus and i have to
go through the airport and it's scary
and it's not okay
but i also think that a man who does
this to me
uh doesn't love me and this is my last
day in america
oh my god 90 day fans fam
the journey has just begun
it seems like a long road is ahead of us
so to stay updated on all the latest
news coming from the 90 day universe
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time
you